من قناه الجزيره في قطر اهلا بكم قال
مسؤولون امريكي رفيع ان الولايات المتحده
اكتشفت من طاد تجسس صينيا فوق الاراضي
الامريكيه وتقوم بتتبعه منذ دخوله مجالها
الجوي قبل عده ايام قادما على ما يبدو من
كندا اضاف المسؤول ان مسار المنطاد يمر
بعدد من المواقع الحساسه لكنه اشار الى ان
تاثيره محدود في جمع المعلومات
الاستخباريه ونقلت شبكه
22 وذلك في حال اتخاذ قرار بالتعامل معه
من جهتها نقلت صحيفه
ان الخارجيه الامريكيه استدعت القائمه
بالاعمال الصيني في واشنطن بشان منطاد
التجسس واضاف ان الهدف من الاستدعاء هو
ارسال رساله واضحه
قال وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي لكوهين انه
قدم لرئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان خلال لقائه بالخرطوم مسوده
اتفاق سلام بين تل ابيب والخرطوم واضاف
كوهين ان الاتفاق هو اتفاق سلام مقابل
سلام وانه سيوقع العمل الجاري بعد تشكيل
حكومه مدنيه في السودان وقد نفى نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده بالسودان محمد حمدان علمه
بزياره الوفد الاسرائيلي واكد انه لم
يلتقي به وقال اعلام مجلس السياده الرئيس
المجلس عبد الفتاح البرهان بحث في مكتبه
في الخرطوم مع وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
والوفد المرافق له تعزيز العلاقات قالت
رابطه اعلاميون من اجل القدس ان حكومه
الفتره الانتقاليه لا تملك حق توقيع اي
اتفاق مع اسرائيل وقال المؤتمر الشعبي ان
الغرض من محاوله التطبيع اليائسه
والمحمومه هو ان يظل السودان تحت حكم
العسكر بدعم من العدو الاسرائيلي
وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويليامبرز لمحادثاته الاخيره مع القاده
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين تركته اكثر
قلقا بشان احتمالات تفاقم العنف بين
الجانبين واضاف بيرنز في كلمه بجامعه
ان ما يحصل اليوم مشابه للوقائع التي
رافقت الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بريانسكا الروسيه
الكسندر الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه تصدت
لهجوم صاروخي اوكراني على بلده
المحاذيه لحدود اوكرانيا واضاف ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت اربعه صواريخ
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان التقديرات
تشير الى ان القوات الروسيه استدعت قرابه
نصف مليون جندي وكشف مجلس الامن القومي
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تستعد لشن
هجوم واسع تزامن ذلك مع توافد للقاده
الاوروبيين على العاصمه قبيل القمه
الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه المقرره اليوم بهدف
تاكيد الدعم الاوروبي لكييف في الحرب مع
روسيا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]